can you go to the neil uh the grace
tyson article okay so so degrasse tyson
says it might be too late to recover
from climate change this is the one
where we had an emotional this is five
years ago or something can you go a
little lower to read it on how he puts
it make it a little bit bigger so i can
read it so neil tyson neil degra de
gracian some of the devastating floods
and hurricanes and we're going to make a
little small que they go in an interview
with cnn gps tyson got emotional when
fareed zakari asked about what made
homeland security advisor thomas refusal
to say whether climate change has been a
factor in hurricane harvey or irma
strength despite scientific evidence
pointing to the fact that it had made
the storms more destructive 50 inches of
rain in houston tyson claimed this is a
shot across our bowl a hurricane the
width of florida going up the center of
florida what will it take for people to
recognize that a community of scientists
are learning objective truths about the
natural world and that you can benefit
from knowing about it and he continued
to say uh
that he had no patience for those who as
he puts a cherry-pick scientific studies
according to their belief system the
press will sometimes find a singular
paper single paper and say oh there's a
new truth if the study holds it but an
emergent scientific truth for it to
become an objective truth the truth that
is true whatever whether or not you
believe in it it requires more than one
scientific paper requires a whole system
of people research all leaning in the
same direction all pointing to the same
kind anyways so he goes on you know
saying the two uh the day two
politicians are arguing about whether
science is true it means nothing gets
done nothing it's the beginning of the
end of an informed democracy as i've
said it many times
what do you think about when you hear
this is this is considered to many
people one of the smartest guys in
america okay so some people this guy's
got billions on top of billions of views
okay adults
kids watch this content they're taught
by by many teachers if he's saying
something like this the average person
says right needle has to be smarter than
you mark to say something and they said
the same thing about anthony fauci when
he first came out
this is what you call science by expert
decree he comes out with this he does it
passionately he's a science spokesman
for decisions that have essentially
already been made he's a science
lobbyist and that's what i call the
united nations climate panel this is a
group of people who are self-selected
who join up and they try to make the
report we have multiple u.n headsets
wait on the next report they'll be so
alarming the world will have to act so
what he's saying first of all what he's
saying about hurricanes it's not first
of all it's not about well this new
study oh skeptics are right we have a
paper in our hand
it's about data and it's about the
complete picture what ends up happening
on climate alarm and he's talking about
a hurricane the width of florida when
current reality fails to alarm you make
up scary predictions of the future and
if you look at this on first of all on
all weather hurricanes floods droughts
tornadoes wildfires there's either no
trend or declining trend and this is
sourced from united nations reports and
there's no way the worst hurricane
decade of the last hundred years was the
1940s the u.n has done multiple extreme
weather reports where they bury this
information but essentially shows
there's either no trend global droughts
there's no trend
global floods there's no trend
but they scare you because they predict
it's going to happen and then he
mentioned houston having 50 inches of
water or whatever it was
the whole nature of extreme weather is
you can always find some extreme
somewhere there's always going to be a
record broken
liking it to a lottery the odds of you
winning the lottery are low the odds of
someone winning the lottery are almost
100 at some point or maybe some weeks
they don't if you're doing a pick six or
something but that what his job is is to
highlight the lottery winners and make
it look like everyone's winning in this
case he's highlighting one city with 50
inches of rain and making it look like
that's happening globally when in
reality it's not global floods so if you
look at the actual trends of all the
underlying data it's not there and by
the way i'm seeing sea level go by here
sea level's been rising since 20 000
years ago the end of the last ice age
sea level by tide gauges the level has
been rising since 20 years ago twenty
thousand years twenty thousand in the
end
yeah it's been a natural rise so first
of all sea level has always been rising
for twenty thousand plus years second of
all if you look at tide gauges it's
about the thickness of a nickel rise per
year and if you look at satellite which
they started in 93 i think it's like
triple or maybe double that rate or
maybe a one and a half times that rate
but there's dueling data sets and even
if you accept their high end it would
take
3 500 years to get the sea level rise
that al gore warned about in his film
and inconvenient truth 3 500 3 500 years
if you were to believe humans were
accelerating it but the point is sea
level rise is natural if you're worried
about sea level rise you could look at
what the dutch did there's all sorts of
things you can do with that and that
requires development economic growth and
also wise building plans you don't want
to put all these houses on the beach
because it's a natural thing happening
anyway so
but it's important to go back to the
neil tyson degrasse because that is
expert
judgment expert consensus that's the way
they've done this that goes back to the
whole 97 percent consensus
these are scientists people trust them
you know four out of five dentists
recommend this toothpaste 97 a scientist
says we had richard toll who i
interviewed was a lead author of the
united nations report looked into the 97
consensus done by an australian named
john cook the underlying data he said
the consensus in that paper was quite
literally pulled from thin air
there's another paper of 97 and they got
a survey of 10 000 scientists whittled
it down to 77 and they came up with 75
answered the the survey is the earth
warming to humans contribute they came
out with a 97 consensus that way even
though there were questions a lot of
skeptical scientists would answer yes to
so this is important because when you
cut to the covet debate you put out a
credentialed expert who makes these
claims puts a little bit of data in but
and then tries to scare the public
because they're lobbying he's lobbying
you for a policy position there are you
basically saying that neil degrasse
tyson is the anthony fauci of climate
change i don't know enough about him i
don't think he's that bad no okay but i
do think he's lobbying for he's lobbying
it's not just he's not that bad he
doesn't have that kind of power right he
doesn't have that anthony
anthony thought she had actually power
and influence neil is is
also more careful i think generally than
falci fauci was just all over the place
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]